he is LSU football's head coach as well
as the National Champion head coach and
the man who was sending the presumed
first overall pick into the draft and
Joe burrow he is at origin Ron how are
you coach oh I'm doing great I'm doing
fine my family's happy and healthy I'm
doing everything that I need to try and
stay safe and staying away from from
anything that I don't need to be at and
and I know that that's something that
you spoke to in a video this week and
I'd love to give you the floor on that
coach oh yeah you know I thought it was
pretty important the governor approach
Mia I'm doing the PSA for protection
against the corona virus and you know
they made the script and I read the
script and I thought it was very good
talking about having the game plan but
about the seriousness of this disease
now country but you know what we need to
fight it we need to battle it we need to
take precautions and protect our family
protect our team and that's what we're
doing here at LSU now I and I'm sure you
know you in particular certainly in that
state and I think nationally it's it's
an important voice yours coach not only
because it's very distinctive but also
because there's tons of Millennials
college kids that may not be taking this
as seriously as they should that maybe
they hear it from you it might mean
something what the government the
government is telling us to protect
ourselves don't go out and have to just
protect ourselves we got to even this
thing out we're in the battle either
battle or something very big across this
country but you know what I know this
country I know the people in this
country we will fight and we'll get it
right what did you when did you first
realize that this might affect your
football season and your preparation for
the next football season coach obviously
yes everything was changing day by day
by day we heard things were things are
shutting down
and then all of a sudden they tell me
the school shut down and everything is
closed and wake room is closed so you
know and we took it very serious most of
our young men went home
I've been with homeless of workouts they
keep doing their own obviously not at a
gym we just got the weather the storm
but their health and their concern is
first with us eddore Geron LSU Tigers
head coach here on the Rich Eisen show
spring practice is is history do you
have any you have any idea any sense or
any planning about when you think
college football might be back on a
gridiron in a manner that is as close to
normal have you have you had any
conversations with anybody about getting
back out there when to expect it you
know it's pretty much unknown to be
honest with you they said the date April
15 which made me that data or maybe push
back hopefully that we could some days
back maybe in June or something like
that
I don't know but obviously I want to
start camping August and hopefully all
this we have this we have this thing
taken care of how is this affecting
recruiting coach in terms of you know
how you're contacting anybody or clearly
traveling and in-home visits are going
to be verboten for for the time being
how has this affected that part of your
job the weekend that they said that they
couldn't visit anybody he was at the
airport with his parents and we had to
send them back home so obvious is it's
affecting on campus visits but we do
have enough time now that nobody's at
school some of our coaching office we
are Texans recruit through that home
with calling them so that's an advantage
for us right now but I think everybody's
on hold and everybody's protecting their
family for sure Edwards you're on LSU
Tiger head coach right here on the Rich
Eisen show you had you sent I believe 16
or 17 kids to the combine this year from
LSU how often is your phone been ringing
off the hook from NFL scouts coaches
about your kids yeah you know although
they're very talented they're very
pleased with the character of our young
men and that's what I talk to most
County
koujun about and obviously they let bug
Joubert oh well I think it's gonna be
the number one guy in the draft we have
a possibility of having six first-round
picks in the draft but we're very
probably what is your take on the sense
that prevailed all the way through the
Superbowl and up to the combine and
perhaps even past the combine that Joe
borough wants no part of Cincinnati and
is trying to avoid being drafted first
overall because I don't think he wants
to be the top pick he wants to compete
so that it still stays on so I think
this would be perfect for okay so you
don't think there's any there there have
you had any conversations with him on
that front and oh no not really
yeah we're not to talk about that I know
Joe Joe's heart he's a competitor and I
would be shocked if that what came out
of Joe burrows ball and then when it
comes to the rest of your tiger grouping
which one you want to pound the table
for that might not be on the radar
screen of a lot of NFL fans that you
think should be drafted it should be
drafted higher than might be the stock
that's been placed in him so far coach
you know I don't know where they applied
it was the lair but he was a along with
Joe burrow he was a different style team
the young man is electric I told
everybody when Clyde walks into the room
he's 64 to 70 and he's not a tremendous
job he was a running back that broke
tackles he caught them all on in the
backfield he empty package a tremendous
young man and yeah I mean when did you
first hear of him his story is
fascinating to me coach coach that was a
year I became interim coach hmm we kept
him we had the pike form but we watch
the film we evaluate and we knew he'd be
a good football player I always thought
that he was underrated
he reminded me a lot of Maurice
jones-drew
who we had to go against when I was at
USC we thought he always he'd be a great
back but he developed here at LSU and
the being one of the best backs we've
had here a long time and you know coach
swinging when deshaun Watson was coming
out
hee-hee Watson wasn't being talked about
first overall and he said that he was
Michael Jordan and cleats and anybody
who passed him up was gonna regret it
and that anybody didn't put a first
round great on him should be fired from
their job what what what is burrow and
cleats would you would you say that he's
got some sort of comparison to whom in
your estimation you know I don't know
myself Tom Brady okay we lost coach oh
just was dimension of Tom Brady cause
the phone line to go dead Oh we'll get
coach Oh back coach there okay we just
lost you when you were comparing him to
who Tom Brady I think that I'm not
saying he's gonna be Tom Brady gonna
have the success he has but I do believe
that Joe has the smarts then tangibles
bet it takes to be a championship
quarterback when I watch the Patriots
playing I see Tom Brady jewelry buyers
got a lot of them now
I don't know Tom Brady personally but I
would assume that Joe has some of the
traits that he has that you can't
measure in the quarterback so then what
what when you see Brady play goes oh
that does look like power to me like
what about that winner a winner he wants
the ball in his hands he believes he's
gonna win every game you get celebrating
the ball with with 46 seconds left and
he's now about seven the likelihood of
him winning he's gonna win he's won a
lot of games at the end he leads his
football team and Joe gave us the sense
in every game that we were gonna win
even though we're down by 10 against
Clemson
nobody ever break because we knew Joe
would take us off the hole and you think
he could could he handle that comparison
coach well I think Joe can handle
anything he has that kind of mentality
has that kind of grip to him
you sawed-off to the game he is not shy
about anything Joseph's competitor and
he's ready for this NFL and you know New
England is losing Tom as you may have
heard earlier today you've already lost
your Brady to the NFL in Joe Brady what
is your what is your plan to once LSU
football starts up again to replace such
a crucial part of your staff coach well
you know I hire Scotland and you know
it's got it been cool yeah st. Louis
Rams NFL defensive coordinator a lot of
experience one of the things I hired him
because he called third down defenses I
throw down offenses obviously he called
the red zone that's where Joe Brady did
plus I think Scott Linehan is a
fantastic fit for us and to replace Joe
pearl we have a young man and miles
Bernie has a very strong arm he's
matured on the job or I think he's gonna
be an outstanding quarterback and coach
as they're rumors are flying right now
as you and I are talking about Cam
Newton perhaps not being the quarterback
for Joe Brady and the Panthers as it
looks like they're gonna part ways and
there's a lot of finger-pointing as to
who has created that and that
Bridgewater
Teddy Bridgewater might come in how do
you think just again I know this is
potentially not your area of staring
down an area of expertise but how do you
think Bridgewater would fit into what
Joe Brady has done you at least know
what his mind would work like in terms
of what quarterback Edina I felt might
work why obviously Joe was with Teddy
Bridgewater's hope there's a connection
there he worked with him he saw grew up
under Sean Payton who's one of the best
offensive minds out there so I can see
that connection I don't I guess that
we're assuming that but I can see that
connection no questions all right coach
I've before I do let you go sir one more
moment if you don't mind to just tell
anybody that you might have any sway
with in an age group that may not be
taking the coronavirus seriously enough
please I give you the floor on that
yeah this is not the play would urge
everyone to take this coronavirus very
serious do the necessary things it takes
to protect yourself your family in our
country no Tigers